can i ask how you guys met did you get  set up on a date  we were filming a movie and  uh which i which ironically i took  because  the only the only reason i took the  movie was because they were like your  scenes with megan fox and i was like  i'll take the movie and um  but i  stayed outside the trailer and  my gut is  always right and i'm grateful for it  because  for some reason i knew she would invite  me to lunch and then all of a sudden  someone came over and they were like  megan wants to know if you want to have  lunch in a trailer  and i was like  oh my god i'm so surprised yeah  absolutely had like a whole bag packed  like  like and uh i went in there and uh  she said  how do you feel and i said i'm lost and  she said let's find you and i was like  it killed me i was like she i mean she  she was cupid and i was i was  you got hit by her arrow